Narrator:
It is the cold hand of nightfall that open
the door to our deepest fears.
Narrator:
For most, it is only a creeping dread,
scratching at the corner of our mind.
Narrator:
But for one family in 1977’s London…
dread, was just the beginning.
I am starting the Enfield poltergeist
case.
Narrator:
What you’re seeing
Is a re-imagining of those events.
Narrator:
But what you’re about to hear…
is real.
PEGGY:
What do you want? Tell us what you want.
(Scream)
That’s an 11-year old girl.
Narrator:
Experience the original recordings.
It was like someone was
knocking to come in.
(Gasp)
(Knocking)
Narrator:
In the chilling, new, docuseries.
GROSSE:
People witnessed Janet levitating.
(Screaming)
PEGGY:
I know what I experienced and I know
that it was real.
♪♪
(Knocking)